There always seems to be room for a few more
bad guys in the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
and if the MCU's going to introduce a few
more villains next time around, here's how
they could expand to include some of their
best, and weirdest, comics bad guys in Avengers
4.
One of the most interesting aspects of Infinity
War is that Thanos' infamous snap of the fingers
straight-up killed people, rather than erasing
them from existence.
That means there are a lot of superheroes
in that world who are dead, and since it stands
to reason that at least a few of them will
make it back to the land of the living, that
means that they've got to be somewhere else
in the meantime.
That opens up the possibility of introducing
Mephisto, the Marvel Universe's most prominent
take on the devil.
There are even connections that are already
waiting to be explored.
Mephisto's role as a bargainer means that
he could be in the perfect position to trade
something for the heroes' lives.
We know from Doctor Strange that Tony Stark
staying alive is necessary for the heroes
to win, so maybe there's something Tony has
that Mephisto wants.
Maybe Captain America is going to strike a
deal to bring back his two best friends.
Or, considering that Mephisto was the one
who drove Nakia to become a supervillain in
the comics by exploiting her love for T'Challa,
maybe she'll be the one who has to make a
sacrifice to bring the Black Panther back
from the dead.
There's another fun piece of the finger-snap:
it's not just Earth that's affected.
It's explicitly mentioned several times that
Thanos is killing half the universe, which
means that all of those spacefaring societies
that we've seen in the Guardians of the Galaxy
movies have also been hit.
That leaves outer space weakened and destabilized
on a cosmic scale, making it the perfect time
for a galaxy-conquering supervillain to show
up and start destroying things.
And there’s no one better than for that
role than Annihilus.
In the comics, he's essentially a sentient
space locust hellbent on devouring everything
in his path across the galaxy.
Since Thanos has apparently retired to a farm
at the end of Infinity War, temporarily shifting
the focus to a more vicious threat could be
a good way to show how big the stakes have
gotten.
Half the universe dying is bad, but it's better
than the other half being wiped out by a dude
who calls himself The Living Death.
If the MCU is looking to introduce a villain
that could rival Thanos, then they might decide
to go with one of the greats: Doctor Doom.
Decades of stories where he fights Iron Man,
Doctor Strange, and even Spider-Man have shown
us that he’s adaptable and powerful enough
to pose a threat to anyone, including Thanos
himself.
He’s even one of the few villains to team
up with the heroes in the original Infinity
Gauntlet story, and has had designs on the
stones more than a few times in the years
since.
Of course, there's an obvious sticking point
here.
Despite his career of fighting the whole Marvel
Universe, Doom will always be the arch-nemesis
of the Fantastic Four, and the film rights
to those characters were held by Fox.
With the news that Disney was buying out Fox
and getting those rights back, however, the
FF could eventually find a home in the MCU.
It’s pretty much inevitable, although Kevin
Feige has said that there are only "vague
ideas" about how to bring those characters
into the MCU, and that the next few movies
(including Avengers 4) were set in stone well
before the buyout.
While it's tempting to focus solely on massive
cosmic threats, there’s plenty of room for
more minor villains to step into the spotlight
and take advantage of the chaos that results
from half the population of a planet turning
to dust.
Believe it or not, that makes Avengers 4 the
perfect opportunity to introduce the Jackal,
best known as the villain directly responsible
for the infamous Clone Saga.
Peter Parker is one of the characters who
gets dusted by Thanos, meaning that there's
currently no place for one of Marvel's flagship
characters in the next film.
There are ways around that, of course, Homecoming
already hinted at the existence of Miles Morales,
but they could always decide that a clone
of Peter is a good way to go.
If that seems unlikely, consider this: in
the comics, the Jackal is Miles Warren, who
was one of Peter's college professors before
he got obsessed with cloning Spider-Man and
Gwen Stacy.
She’s never named in the film, but if you
look at the credits for Homecoming, you’ll
find that Orange Is the New Black's Selinis
Leyva plays a teacher named Ms. Warren.
Maybe it’s a coincidence, but with the MCU,
you never know.
One of the more unexpected moments of Infinity
War involved a reappearance from the Red Skull
as a cosmic harbinger of doom.
Since he's Captain America's arch-nemesis,
it makes sense that he would somehow find
his way back into action, but now it seems
that Brock Rumlow, a.k.a. Crossbones, is going
to be back in Avengers 4 in some way, too.
At this point, that could mean anything from
a flashback sequence to a scene in the afterlife,
but it could also mean that we'll be seeing
characters returning from the dead who weren't
just snapped into dust.
If that's the case, then why stop at Skull
and Bones?
Why not go all out with the whole dang Skeleton
Crew?
Admittedly, Mother Night and Minister Blood
aren't exactly going to set the world on fire,
but they're no more or less well-known than
Proxima Midnight and Corvus Glaive, so hey,
why not?
Finally, we have the character who is quite
possibly the most Marvel Comics of all the
Marvel villains: M.O.D.O.K., the Mental Organism
Designed Only for Killing.
The MCU has gotten weird enough that we've
seen Eitri the Dwarf, the Grandmaster, and
a cameo appearance from Beta Ray Bill.
Arnim Zola has been in two movies, and while
he admittedly never appeared in his true comic
book form as a big robot dude with a TV face
in his chest, Winter Soldier brought him pretty
close.
So why not follow up the biggest and most
devastating superhero movie of all time by
throwing in the Mental Organism Designed Only
for Killing?
He’s not the the giant head in a flying
rocket chair that we want.
He’s the giant head in a flying rocket chair
that we need.